[музика]
нормально супер
а я ходжу вимагати зарядити мобільний
телефон
всі мої рикам і в прихованій вона виглядає
цю ракету
Юля бомба
[музика]
та актриса
йдіть нишком я не знаю зараза працюють
ще роботи кал з рамку на вітрі на
тривога Ну ось мені і ти мені підсікати я
потекла 7 мені сказала виходить за годину на
23 лютого я правильно розумію я
[музика]
безпеки це ніяк не впливає на це
взагалі не вплине це ніяк не
вплинула на хід спеціальна траса
[музика]
ми колись заїхали в Україну скрізь На
парканах написам російські окупанти будемо
[ __ ] це цікаво наша бригада
безпосередньо обосралась армія У нас тупа
дебіли просто не розумію
тому що це закінчена організація
бухі всі сині сука і всім [ __ ] те що
зараз
все якось таке передноворічний
настрій
[музика]
зараз
продовжуєш інтерес у тебе залишається
коли поїдете додому проїхати через
Москву зупинитися подивитися льодове
шоу
Левове озеро
[музика]
Вова розумієш за відвагу ти перебиваю
вас пандорочка він двигун поліз Чому
взагалі поломка літака винищувач
звідки сталася туди залетів Білла
голуб з України
діставати бідні
лапки
що було написано
скабеєва показала
Азов Рядовий пташка
нічого Не приховаєш від наших ГБ Я думаю
що це тистребитель були захоплені
байденівцем що насправді за кермом
цього винищувача були не наші росіяни
аси наші російські аси такого б ніколи
не зробили це було захоплення винищувача у
польоті там навіть є відео як підлітає
інший винищувач
жовток цим синім прапором і захоплює
винищувач прямо в польоті і цей
винищувач летить прямо в будинок частково
руйнуючи його
не це було негативна посадка так і
сказали ж я вірю Федеральним каналам
як може державний канал брехати
Такі цікаві
негативна посадка все
[музика]
крихти защіпають
за Україною
[музика]
Слава Україні
все зрозуміло хіба
слово Поляни
який Степан
Бандера
ти плачеш, бо помер Степан
[музика]
твою матір за 40 гривень штани
сказав це курити сьогодні українська
армія знатно
повернутий контроль над правим Дніпра
вже наступна
що там за ситуація на Херсонщині
[музика]
і коротше це
туди сюди
[музика]